Mr. Roy, a pleasure
to welcome you home.
Oh, I don't recall people
shedding a tear when I left.
JESSE ARMSTRONG: It's a
pretty touching episode to make
because Brian Cox, the actor,
comes from Dundee in Scotland.
He was the guy driving around
places he knew from his youth
as he plays Logan,
being a guy driving around
places that he knows
from his youth, so,
it was very affecting
to see that.
This place, you look
at the old pictures
and they all want you
to think it's all
so fucking simple,
but it wasn't.
What they say, you know?
ARMSTRONG: In the writer's room,
we always knew there was
an element of tragedy
in his early life.
There it is.
What am I supposed to do?
I think maybe a photo.
They've said you can go in.
No, thank you.
Let's go.
Ahh, memories.
-Marcia, you look lovely.
-Oh, thank you.
Uh, so--
Something I wanted to ask you...
ARMSTRONG: Marcia,
she doesn't come from the same
cultural background
as the rest of the characters,
and so her rhythms
are slightly different.
Are you regularly tested for
sexually transmitted diseases?
Excuse me?
(CHUCKLES NERVOUSLY)
He and I still sleep together,
so I would be more relaxed
to know that you are clean.
And I think she shocks people
and puts them on their heels,
so it was interesting
seeing her do that to Rhea.
(STAMMERS)
This isn't appropriate talk--
When I lose...
the other one will generally
lose an eye or so.
CROWD: Surprise!
Rhea organizes what we call
the Logan-athon.
She thinks it will be nice.
LOGAN ROY: Jesus H. Christ.
ARMSTRONG: I don't know whether
she's quite judged, exactly,
things that Logan prizes
in life,
which are generally about
going forward,
not huge on the past.
It's a pleasure to have you here
tonight to honor
my dad's life and work.
Rhea asked me to help out
with a little tribute
to the certain, uh, flava.
ARMSTRONG:
The idea of Kendall rapping
was, I remember, I was thinking,
if you heard a billionaire's son
had done that,
it would be like, yeah,
sounds like the sort of
toe-curling thing
you might see on Instagram.
(RAPPING) ♪ L to the O-G
Dude be the OG ♪
♪ A-N, he playin' ♪
ARMSTRONG: It was nice,
and we had that whole V and A
in Dundee that was full
of background people
and people just responded
naturally.
I think it's
pretty embarrassing.
It's also kind of good.